les quiero preguntar quién de ustedes ha
visto a una persona con discapacidad a
lo largo de su vida
o algunos que dicen que no y los invitó
a retirarse porque están mintiendo todos
hemos visto por lo menos a 20 personas
con una discapacidad en nuestra vida
las personas con discapacidad sufren de
dos factores y problemas físicos y
psicológicos para una persona en silla
de ruedas es imposible subir un escalón
cosa que nosotros hacemos diariamente y
para una persona y nosotros nos hacemos
sentir inferiores diferentes y extraños
o sea que no son que yo sepa respira
piensa ven como cada uno de nosotros
pero simplemente por el hecho que no son
igual que nosotros nuestra mente cerrada
hace que pensamos que son diferentes o
inferiores
el día de hoy yo les traigo una idea
para solucionar la parte física y se
llama caminar consiste en una prótesis
ajustable que el amarras con un velcro
en las piernas y tiene un motor detrás
del bíceps para que impulse si tienes un
discapacidad temporal este no te dará
tanto impulso para que tengas una
recuperación mejor pero si es si es de
por vida te dará una te dará un impulso
como a cualquier otra persona y para que
camines igual
si no tienes piernas este de este
proyecto también te puede ayudar ya que
podría incluir unos termo unos tubos con
los que
con los que se más rara es igual con el
velcro para para que parezca que tienes
unas piernas y como igual con el motor
que lo impulsará
sé que muchos de ustedes pueden estar
pensando este es muy futurístico
improbable o costoso tal vez y no los
culpo la primera vez que mi cerebro me
puso esté en frente pensé lo mismo pero
hoy ya está en el proceso de desarrollo
acción con un amigo mío y aunque parezca
complicado sueño con lograrlo el día de
hoy
les presente 33 cosas 1 que sufren las
personas con una discapacidad 2 una
solución para ello y 3 que no hay que
rendirnos por más que nos digan no
puedes es imposible y nunca lo lograrás
si podemos hace 2 días yo sufrí una
conmoción leve y muchos me dijeron mejor
quédate en casa y no vayas algo te puede
pasar pero no hoy estoy aquí así que si
te plantas en el piso y dices yo puedo
tú podrás antes de irme quiero decirles
y ayudar es algo que todos podemos dar
no cuesta nada y no importa que la
persona a la que vayas a ayudar sea una
persona discapacidad discapacitada
porque puede ser tu mejor amigo que esté
en un perfecto estado pero no puede
llevar sus libros ayúdale no cuesta nada
y te da más de lo que tú das gracias
[Aplausos]